Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the opening verses of surah
or which we have reviewed the story and
the context behind these verses. He
tells us subhanahu waala
and these were the first verses to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. An
important point to take here is first
impressions last.
The thing that a person first hears and
the thing that a person last hears from
someone,
those are the things which stick out the
most
in any encounter or dialogue when it
comes to human beings. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has set up the Quran
in that way. every chapter of the Quran.
Most of the chapters that have a
beginning, middle, and end, not the very
short chapters, which are usually all
just one subject matter, but chapters of
the Quran that deal with multiple
subjects,
the very beginning of the chapter, the
opening verses and the very end of the
chapter chapter, the closing verses.
These are the points and most prominent
things that are to be taken away from
each of these chapters. And that's why
in his book
he mentions that
we have no authentic narration
that tells us that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
would
only recite the ends of a chapter in
salah or the openings of a chapter in
salah and not recite anything else.
There are a few
narrations
in which the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam may have recited a
particular verse or a particular section
of a chapter repeatedly.
However, his sunnah was that whenever he
would start a chapter in salah, he would
always end it in that prayer either in
the same or in the following and
subsequent raqa. So anytime he would
start a chapter, he would end it. Why?
Because the beginning and the end of the
chapters they are connected and these
are the most important takeaways. The
beginning of the chapter is usually like
a preface an introduction and it is
going to summarize what is going to be
mentioned in the chapter and the points
that should be mentioned in the chapter.
At the end it derives lessons and leaves
the mood and the attitude of the reader
when he ends that particular chapter. If
we look at the Quran entirely, what was
the beginning? The very first
recite or read.
Notice the double antandra here. This is
referred to. It's a statement that has
multiple meanings that are intended both
simultaneously.
Could mean recite and could mean read
something that is written
contrary to
is mentioned in the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala said recite.
There is a word for recitation which
means just recitation.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala used this
word which means both recite and read.
Why? Because both are intended. And this
recitation will arrive a person at
reading. And this recitation that Allah
is revealing is going to be preserved by
the pen. It is going to be preserved by
men who will memorize it committed to
memory and the pen will serve as a
backup to that institutional memory of
the Muslim and so the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam is commanded
recite in the name of your lord who has
created all of the creation.
He created the humankind from clinging
drops of blood from clinging clots of
blood. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. What is the
first stage the human being goes through
that Allah mentions in his mother's
womb? Does anybody know
what is it?
Is the second stage. What's the first
stage? Nutah is a drop. Right?
So the first stage is a nut
and the last stage just before the soul
is put into the body is the mudra,
right? Which is a a lump of flesh, a
bite-sized lump of flesh, if you will.
The middle stage is the
the clinging clot of blood. Why this
stage?
Why didn't Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mention created the human being from
drops? That's the beginning.
Or created the human being from
a a lump of flesh from a mud because
that's just when the soul is put into
the body. Why the middle stage of the
human evolution in his mother's womb?
The scholars mention because this middle
stage
is the stage when it moves from
inanimate just drops that could or could
not be consequential
or a mudra
where it has already advanced to the
point that it is being formed as a male
or female. But this center stage this
represents the place that the prophet
was at sallall.aii wasallam when he
received the Quran spiritually.
He is receiving the Quran now. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala had kept him pure
throughout his life. He was upon the fra
as much as any human being can remain
upon the fra. Now comes what? The next
stage which is the mudra when the soul
is put into the body and this stage is
achieved spiritually
by way of the Quran's revelation to him
and this is what is meant by the
statement of Allah
in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
light upon light what is light upon
light. The light of revelation
upon the light of the fra the human
preisposition
that the human is created upon the
general knowledge of right and wrong the
general knowledge of good and bad and
the oneness of Allah in a very macro way
a very general way. So this light of the
fra when the light of revelation comes
upon it. This is the believer and here
is the prophet sallall.aii
in this position.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he says
I'm having problems today. He he says
subhanahu waala recite or read and your
lord is the most generous.
This wow here
This wow is called wow.
It means recite
and know that as you recite or read your
lord is the most generous. What does
this mean? This means that if you take a
path to reach something, Allah is more
generous than his servant and his slave.
And Allah will always reciprocate your
effort.
For this reason, the mere act of
stepping onto the path of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to seek knowledge of
Allah and his messenger to seek
knowledge of revelation
immediately a person is put on a path to
paradise.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then says
he taught with the pen
taught the human being what he did not
previously know. Here we have another
double antandra
alma
because in the Arabic language could
mean taught
here means taught by the way of the pen.
and also means
left an imprint in
that which is being imprinted upon.
It left an impression to leave an
impression in something. Where are there
verses similar to this in the Quran?
Allah says in and we will end with this
inshallah.
[Silence]
Why did Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mention it in that order? He's saying
he taught the Quran or he wrote the
Quran in the preserved tablet.
Both of those meanings are intended.
Then he says he created the human being
and taught him
the eloquence of speech and the highest
level of
the highest level of articulation
made the human being articulate. What do
we understand from this? What we would
expect from the way that the verses are
in order? We would expect
alman created the human being
then taught him eloquence in speech and
then taught the Quran because that was
the order with respect to us. However,
that's not the order that it's mentioned
in. It's mentioned alman
he taught he wrote or taught the Quran.
He created the human being. He taught
him eloquence. The scholars derive from
this order that the human being will
never reach his full potential until he
embodies the Quran. That is considered
to be the full potential of the human
being and the human being was created
for that potential. That was the bar
that was set.
He then created the human being and
taught him eloquence in order that he
could live up to his potential which is
the Quran. And that was the plan from
the very very beginning.
Knowledge
is so important in our religion. And I'm
not speaking about knowledge of worldly
things. I'm speaking about knowledge of
the Quran and Sunnah. That is what the
Quran came to encourage. knowledge of
the revelations of Allah. Knowledge
which is heavenly divine knowledge.
This knowledge
is so critical and it is very sad to see
many people confused as to the
importance of knowledge. The general
idea is almost you know, as long
as I have really good intentions
and as long as I just do the best that I
know how to do, I don't have to learn
anything because I'll get to Jenna
eventually cuz Allah said that I'm going
to go to Jenna as long as I sayahillah
and just practice whatever I know. And
I'm either in Jenna or I'm not. This
kind of black and white ideology, this
is what has caused the regression
for the Muslim in their own knowledge
and in their own sciences. Knowledge is
a map. It takes you places. If you
don't have that map, you'll never get to
those places ever. Ever. You will never
be able to access them. It doesn't
matter how sincere you are. The only way
to reach those stations of belief and
eman and that station of relationship
with Allah is if you have that map.
That's the only way to get there.
There's no other way.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
said as much to Omar of all people. Once
Omar told him and the narration is in
Muslim. He said,
Yeah.
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
once was told by Omar wall messenger of
Allah I love you more than everyone
except my own self my own soul
that is what Omar understood at the time
that that was the most a person could
love the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
more than my own soul
more than everything except for my
own self the prophet Sallallah.aii
wasallam said, "No, not until I am even
more beloved to you than your own self."
He said, "Now you are more beloved to me
than my own self."
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
responded, "Now you have reached those
heights." Omar didn't know that before.
He did the best that he knew how. And
had he not been taught by the prophet in
that moment, he would have never reached
that station of belief, impossible. No
matter how
sincere you are, you cannot stumble upon
Allah's pleasure.
You have to know where it is and be
guided to it. That is why prophets and
messengers were sent. Otherwise, people
were sincere before prophethood.
Why do they need prophets to teach them?
Just do your best and do whatever you
can and you'll get there eventually.
Allah's pleasure is not something you
accidentally earn.
[Arabic recitation]